alessandra you just got back from seeing
30 minutes of dying light - and they
described the game as a narrative
sandbox what does that mean for dying
light so basically what that means is
that you're the many of your choices
will you know actually affect the flow
with the narrative the original game had
a pretty like you know linear story but
uh they they view this the the story in
dying light - is more of a sort of a
nebulous like a thing where maybe even
like the miner choices of you know
whether you want to save a particular
character or even if like you side with
this other character like you know
they're an argument with like different
factions will it really change the flow
of the story and you know it could even
like open up different areas of Medicine
can even affect the world so I mean for
example based on what you're saying it
sounds like we could like your final
game could look very or your final Rock
to look very different in mine and it is
it is of course written by or at least
the writing is headed up by Chris Avalon
who's well known for doing RPGs Fallout
series the Fallout series so those sort
of branching narratives are very much
his MO yes but what about the setting
itself I think the setting is way more
interesting than the original one from
what we seen so far is that for one
because of you know the the narrative
sandbox you know creases you know just
this incredible flavor like where my
version of you know dying light - will
be my own and you know and my choices
will actually affect me of the different
areas of the city and also of the city
itself and that's what the the settings
call this called the city okay the city
is actually four times bigger than the
original game so you're covering a lot
more ground and you know because you're
covering a lot of ground you're actually
given the more enhanced like traversal
mechanics as well yeah you're saying
something about a glider right yeah I
can help you get around the city yeah
for one you can use your grappling hook
at any point but also you can isn't can
you grapple onto pretty much anything or
there like specific points that you grab
a lot of there's specific points but um
you can actually use the grappling hook
of I believe there in combat as well oh
okay so there's one swing like pull
zombies close to you think of I didn't
see that but we did see you know the the
player using the grappling hook to sort
of attach this thing ceiling and sort of
use it to create
exactly I really liked it uh but uh
during traversal like you throughout the
city you can use a grappling hook then
sort of launch yourself up to use a
paraglider which which i think is a
really cool feature and uh okay it's
attached to your characters almost like
links glider that he has yeah okay yeah
so you can use it anytime well what
about the combat we talked a little bit
about how you can use the grapple to
enhance combat but he also said they're
trying to kind of make that are trying
to make movement and combat a little
more seamless yes in a lot of ways if I
felt very similar to like Mirror's Edge
in a lot of ways where you know the
combat and the traversal were like sort
of one in the same like they were very
much related to each other like you know
in terms of how your character moved and
also just how they sort of chose to like
engage the enemies like uh you can use
like you know these very sophisticated
dodge mechanics like there's a slow-mo
dodge you can activate which allows you
to like sort of get around the enemy and
hit their weak point is it all about
kind of keeping up momentum to is
definitely important definitely um
because you're going to be running
around a lot and you have to pick your
battles because uh you'll probably find
situations where you're better off just
titling out of hightailing it out of
there and you know trying to you know
maybe like a find better resources to
sort of engage like you know a
particular calendar is there anything
else that stood out to you from what you
saw
for me like I'm I just really
appreciated just the approach to
storytelling it's not something you'd
expect from based on what we saw with
dying light and previous tech laying
games it's really cool that they seems
like they're doubling down yeah they
seem to be taking a lot of the the good
things that dying light did which was
offering like this sort of sandbox like
you know combi playground yeah parkour
yeah but um but they're also like even
things out a bit like where you're
actually fighting a lot more human
enemies this time around but the zombies
are still there and over the course of
the story like a depending on what your
actions are of course you'll see more
the infected sort of come out and like
you know reveal themselves one of the
moments that really stuck with me was a
you know towards the end of the demo
where you basically you know go against
the supposedly evil Colonel who had
access to the city's water pump and uh
activating the water pump would actually
open up a section of the city that you
probably wouldn't have access to like if
you
chosen to go a different way and
activating the water pump would open the
city up at that part of the city up and
it would also reveal certain infected
that have been sort of akin hibernation
in that area and one of the infected
that was revealed a head like spiked
arms and we didn't really see anything
beyond that so I'm very curious to see
like what you know you know a lot of
special infected yeah yeah and they say
they infect it will evolve significantly
compared to the first one in this game
so I'm interested in seeing how that
plays out and that's what all the
Saunders software dying light - it looks
like it's scheduled for a spring 2020
release date yeah
but for more III news make sure to stay
tuned to games
[Music]